i've taken it i've had the booster  many politicians i watched a couple of  politicians be interviewed  and one of the questions was did you get  the booster because they had the vaccine  and they oh they're answering it like in  other words the answer is yes but they  don't want to say it he's very clearly  referring to ron desantis there and this  is already a signal about if desantis  wants to be the nominee in 24 and trump  wants to be the nominee in 24 it's going  to get very ugly very quickly which i  love because they're gutless you gotta  say it  whether you had it or not say it  but the fact is that i think the vaccine  has saved  tens of millions of people throughout  the world  i have had absolutely no side effects  i've had it like other people have had  it nothing special  so donald trump here  is  he  other than the fact that he takes credit  for the vaccines for which he deserves  no credit the the u.s pre-purchase doses  that's all they did